[Music]
welcome everyone i'm calvin french owen
CTO and co-founder of segments and today
i'd like to share a few of the things
that we've been up to at segments now
I'd like to start off by highlighting
the elephant in the room today you're
making a hard choice you have to pick
between the three big cloud providers in
terms of choosing where to build your
infrastructure you pick Amazon thought
to be the market leader you could pick
Microsoft thought to have the best
enterprise solutions or you could pick
an or sorry you could pick Google
thought to have the best technology now
you know that when you make that choice
you're probably gonna be walked in by
some amount of switching cost and more
likely than not maybe a one to three
year commitment and moreover it's going
to have lasting ramifications on things
like the cost of your infrastructure
maybe your performance that you're able
to get maybe it's even your ability to
deliver a final product on time and
under budget now its segment this was
the position we found ourselves in about
a year and a half ago we were trying to
deliver a new product personas we kept
hitting the limits of what the Amazon
infrastructure could do for us so we
started turning our attention to other
options out on the table and the ones we
found were on Google cloud in particular
using two products bigquery and BigTable
allowed us to build out our new product
personas and deliver it to our users and
create millions of dollars of revenue in
a single year today I'd like to leave
you on a journey through personas its
underlying architecture and how we've
leveraged these two different cloud
products to deliver a fully finished
product I'm hoping that you can take
some of the lessons away and apply them
to your own infrastructure when it comes
to building on top of Google Cloud
so let's dive in as part of today's
roadmap I'd like to start out with a
little bit of background
what is segments how does it work then
we'll transition to the architecture
personas itself how it's built and what
use case is designed to address before
diving in deep to understand how it's
built on top of both bigquery and
BigTable finally we'll revisit some of
those hard choices that we've had to
make in production ourselves and talk
about some of the trade-offs that we see
now and going forward so a bit of
background
what is segments what's the scale that
we're seeing today for those of you
might not be familiar segments gives you
a single API to collect data about your
users these might be things like users
loading pages on your website
maybe it's signing up via your mobile
app maybe it's completing orders on your
online checkout whatever it is your
users are doing things with your app and
you want to know who they are and why
they're doing the things that they're
doing concurring what that looks like is
that segment gives you the set of
sources that you see on the left these
are places where your data lives whether
it's your mobile app website or maybe a
source like Stryper Zendesk we all take
that data into one consistent place and
then get it into hundreds of different
sass tools that you might be using over
on the right these could be data
warehouses like redshift or bigquery
maybe it's an email tool like customer
i/o or Zendesk or maybe it's an
analytics tool like Google Analytics or
Mixpanel whatever it is segment helps
you get that single source of truth
about your data into all those different
destinations now by the numbers this has
taken us to some interesting places
today we collect the data for 19,000
users every single month and in terms of
our intake we process about 300 billion
events every single month as well that
translates to roughly 450 billion
outbound API calls that we're making and
processing terabytes of data per day now
today all of this infrastructure has run
on Amazon
it's running in Amazon's compute
environment and we're processing all
that data using ECS and a fleet of
16,000 containers and under the hood it
looks something a little bit like this
we have our API at the front door which
is ingesting events
it's then publishing those two Kafka
which we use as our primary message bus
where we're collecting all these
different sorts of events and then from
there we have a consumer who's reading
each message reading from a database and
figuring out where that data should be
sent and then deciding to send that data
to certain destinations
maybe this event is bound for Google
Analytics this other one is built for
Salesforce another one is even sent to
Mixpanel
and maybe we have one which is supposed
to go to all of the above now there's a
really big advantage of the system in
the way that we've architected it and
that's that it's stateless if we want to
add more capacity to the system it gives
us more throughput we can simply just
double the amount of collection points
the amount of Kafka brokers the amount
of consumers and really the only shared
thing here is our database but maybe we
can get past that with some Reid
replicas and some caching in our case
it's really easy to just scale out more
capacity as our load doubles triples 10
exes or 50 exes it kind of doesn't
matter but in 2018 our product teams
started giving us a new set of
requirements in particular it was to
launch this new product called personas
the idea was to take segments from this
place which simply streamed individual
events around where each event maybe
doesn't have any correlation to the
others to actually creating the idea of
a user profile something that's a little
more holistic who tells you what the
user is and what they're doing hopefully
it should tell you a little bit about
who they are where they've been and
allow you to query that in real time now
as you might guess this use case is
decidedly stateful we can't any longer
just add nodes to our infrastructure and
expect them all to fan out and kind of
work in this magical way I said now we
actually have to pull our data together
and put it into one spot so that if we
query it we get it both consistent
and available answer to give you a
better sense of what these staple use
cases look like let me walk you through
the three use cases up personas the
first one is what we call the profile
API the general idea here is that we
have some set of information about the
user who they are what they've done and
we want to be able to pull that
information programmatically
now there's two use cases which we found
this for the biggest one is for building
personalization systems in your web app
let's say you're running an online store
you sell all different types of pants
men's pants women's pants kids pants if
you've seen a user come back in the past
ten times in the last month and they've
only looked at men's pants maybe you
should change up your homepage make it
guide them a little bit towards finding
only men's pants so they don't have to
click around and potentially abandon
your entire checkout flow the second use
case after the profile API for
personalization is around identity
resolution as I said before we're
collecting data from many different
places maybe it's your web app maybe
it's your mobile app maybe it's another
source like Zendesk or stripe each of
those users may get a different identity
may it's their email may it's the ID
that you have in your user database or
maybe it's something else like a stripe
customer ID we want to be able to take
those different individual identifiers
and unify them so if you want to query
for a user it doesn't matter if they're
a Calvinist
if they're XYZ one two three or stripe
some other see us underscore whatever we
want to be able to say here's Calvin
here's my user finally the third use
case after the Profile API an identity
resolution is audience computation now
for those of you who might not be
familiar and I certainly wasn't when I
we first started segment and audience is
just a group of people who meet certain
criteria you want to be able to specify
certain rules to say hey which of my
users have visited three times in the
past month started a checkout flow last
week but then never completed it
personas gives you this ability to
create those arbitrary rules and then
find that list of users
so that's personas you in query users in
real time via the profile API match them
by identity and then create audiences of
users as well let's take a look at how
it's architected under the hood now I
wanted to start by first talking about
lambda architectures and don't worry I'm
at the right conference this is a
different type of lambda architecture
than the server list one you might be
hearing about now this lambda
architecture actually comes from the sky
Nathan Mart's who was at Twitter and he
kept coming up with these concepts of
how he could process lots and lots of
data in real time and he wanted to
ensure that he could crunch both large
amounts of data
eventually terabytes or petabytes but
also get a good real-time view of
individual parts of analysis that he's
running and so he came up with a system
that you see behind me the general idea
is that new data comes in via a single
source but then it's written twice first
it's written to a batch layer some sort
of job that's running maybe hourly or
daily is doing big roll-ups and
aggregations of a bunch of different
pieces of data from there he also writes
data to what he calls a speed layer you
could think of this as being something
like Kafka or the queue that we've been
keeping track of this effectively has
the diff of whatever the batch layer has
then at query time you effectively want
to pull those two pieces together you
can grab your big aggregation that you
have as well as your little real-time
updates that you've been making now if
you look at this we have a few different
use cases here we have batch
computations we have speed to get us the
best of both worlds in terms of
aggregation and in terms of real-time
updates it actually doesn't look that
different from what we want on personas
we want to be able to query our profiles
in real time and match users by identity
and we want those actions to happen
incredibly quickly ideally under a
second we also want to create audiences
of users
and this is where we scan terabytes of
data and maybe it's okay if it takes a
few minutes or maybe even an hour to
come back now you might be thinking well
it sounds like you have different
pipelines with different requirements
why not use different data stores and
that's exactly what we did we
effectively have our single message bus
than Kafka then publishing to cloud
pub/sub and from there we have two
separate sets of workers who are writing
the data twice one set of workers is
writing that data into bigquery to do
batch processing to create those
audiences the second set of workers are
writing into BigTable to give us real
time results and updates I'm going to
start on the left hand side of this
diagram before moving into the right to
really explore some of these use cases
now for those of you who are familiar
Kafka and pub/sub both are this kind of
idea of a message bus each one can take
individual messages and then replicate
them for delivery to give you a better
sense of what segment messages actually
look like I've included example over
here on the right segment messages
involve tracking things like page views
user events maybe it's completed order
events whatever it is here I just took
an example from my blog typically these
are semi structured JSON so segments as
part of our API spec we specify that
there are a few top-level fields that
you need these would be things like the
user ID the event name maybe a timestamp
to let us know when the event happened
but the rest is all filled in by our
customers depending on what's important
to them so for example here you can see
that there are a few custom properties
it's the name of the article maybe it's
the refer if you're running a music app
maybe it's something like the song title
or the artist whatever it is we can't
really anticipate it ahead of time
it's just our users sending it into our
API so that's a key part of our data
processing pipeline and typically these
messages run to about one kilobyte in
terms of average though they may span up
to 32 kilobytes depending on how much
stuff is just packed into that
to give you a sense of what this
actually looks like from a code
perspective I've included basically a
light version of the code that takes
data from Kafka and publishes it into
pub/sub effectively we iterate over a
range of messages here we create a
payload of them tagging each message
with its type and collection base like
what sort of thing it is whether it's a
user product or an account we pack that
all into JSON and then we compress it
via snappy and then we ship it off to
pub/sub and from there we're trying to
analyze these hundreds of thousands of
one kilobyte messages where for one
branch we send it into our batch
computations in bigquery and for the
second branch we send into the real-time
computations in BigTable
so let's dive into each of those
bigquery and cloud BigTable for each one
I'd like to compare them first on the
use case that we're trying to achieve
second the underlying architecture
pulled from the best of my understanding
from white papers and papers that are
published externally by Google third
we'll talk about their data model what
it actually looks like to store segment
data in these systems and then fourth
will discuss the query patterns how
we're actually using this in production
so let's revisit this use case on the
top here we have the worker which is
running and loading data into bigquery
and because this is a batch job we can
run it let's say every 15 minutes or
kind of whatever schedule we want
separately we're running and then
computing this data via the compute
service which is effectively just
running a cron job to calculate
audiences for our users every so many
minutes and again we want to find users
who meet arbitrary criteria here we
don't know what those criteria are ahead
of time it's up to our users to specify
them
we have terabytes of data sitting in the
system and we need to get responses
within a few minutes but it doesn't have
to be seconds milliseconds nanoseconds
we rarely care about all of the columns
which is pretty key oftentimes we'll be
only trying to say hey
who are users who have done event X more
than Y times or maybe find the only
users in San Francisco in this case
we're picking one tiny part of our
information and then extracting a list
of user IDs and again real time reads
are not a big deal here we need maybe
only tens of concurrent queries to
satisfy our user base and so as long as
we're able to get that we're good so
let's look at what bigquery looks like
under the hood now I'm gonna do a quick
history lesson here internally at Google
there have been a number of systems for
crunching large amounts of data and back
in 2004 kind of the seminal paper on
this was called MapReduce and at the
time Google was trying to compute
basically the entire index of the web
sounds like a small goal right
and so with MapReduce they said hey we
want to be able to call the entire web
and we want to be able to figure out
PageRank for each of these pages we want
to be able to say which pages are the
most popular based upon which pages then
link to them and so MapReduce was this
internal system that Google had where as
the programmer you need to write two
functions you need to write a map
function and a reduced function as long
as you've specified those two things and
then pass in your data set you be able
to get your results back within maybe
hours or maybe the next day but it was
the best thing that they had for
literally web-scale data at the time so
they used it and they're able to parse a
lot of freeform text but then in 2010 a
new paper came out called Dremel and
this is really the basis for a big query
now in the paper they say that this has
actually been put around since 2006 but
Dremel was designed to solve a different
set of problems than MapReduce in
particular is designed for interactive
analysis now you can think of Dremel as
sort of being the internal version of
bigquery but in terms of how they're set
up my understanding is that roughly the
same for bigquery and Dremel that
interactive piece is key now instead of
being an analyst you had to wait hours
or maybe overnight to get back
results you just get them within a few
minutes so if you were exploring your
data you could actually give you a
really good sense of what was in it the
other big advantage of Dremel and
bigquery was that you sequel rather than
programming before you might end up
writing a big MapReduce job saying yes
this looks great and then you ship it
off to whatever your MapReduce or maybe
externally a Hadoop cluster looks like
then when you come back it turns out
some part of your program had erred
which means that you have to run the
entire thing again because bigquery and
Dremel use sequel it meant that it was
accessible to your average analyst and
could get you back data as well as
errors in a very very quick time scale
additionally it uses nested structure
data which I'll talk about a little bit
more here rather than the freeform text
that MapReduce just says okay you have
some sort of input of bytes and output
in particular I'd like to highlight four
good ideas that are all pulled from the
Dremel and bigquery paper and these are
all ideas that we've used to
successfully scan terabytes of data
within a few minutes the first idea is
being column oriented and let me talk a
more about what this means
suppose we want to build a database we
want to create something where I can add
data to it I can query it and I know
that that rate data is somehow written
durably how might we do it
well let's assume we're doing the dead
simple thing here and I'm just adding to
a flat file where each row involves a
new row in my database or a new record
may first I have the name of the
engineer on my team may I have their job
position maybe I have
how many contributions they've had in
the last year and then maybe I have
their location and on the face of this
this kind of looks like a standard
database right it's like if I want more
rows I can add them to the end if I
update I could update in place or I
could potentially add to the end and
merge later it just seems like it does
what I want just as a flat file
but now let's get back to our problem
statement what if my database has
billions of rows and I only need one of
them what if I only need the location
data for example remember we want to be
able to scan all this data incredibly
quickly well the good idea that bigquery
had is hey let's store columns not rows
if we look back at my super simple
database example here instead of storing
a single file with each row indicating a
record let's instead split them up
let's keep one file for each column then
if I want to grab the location itself
it's easy I just read the location file
and now I don't have to parse through
all of this unnecessary data that maybe
I don't care about for things like the
person's name or their role or how many
contributions they've had I don't have
to split those commas do all that CSV
processing instead I just get what I
want and under the hood it turns out
that bigquery and Dremel do the same
exact thing instead of storing rows as
records or records as rows rather they
keep columns which individual nodes can
store so if you only need to grab one
thing you can just skin super quickly
and then you get your result back the
second good idea is actually related to
being column oriented and that's using
compression as you might have noticed if
I have all of these columns on disk San
Francisco San Francisco Tokyo San
Francisco San Francisco we have a lot of
repeated data here and in particular if
I need to scan all that data on disk or
if it's from AB acting data file store I
need to do a lot of network transfer
costs as well as just raw seeking of the
data itself so instead we can compress
it by using something I like run length
encoding the general idea here is that
let's say I have 200 entries which all
have San Francisco as the entry I can
now encode them and say San Francisco
200 before reading the next column which
maybe is Tokyo 1 and then maybe I have
another San Francisco 100 in practice
when I have a really really big data set
this makes scanning
and parsing it much much quicker so we
have column-oriented and compression the
third idea that I'd like to touch on is
an efficient nested encoding and I'll
get back to why this is important in a
few minutes but to give you a sense of
what exactly this is bigquery gives you
the ability to specify what your data
looks like here it's represented as
protobufs which is a technology that we
also use internally at segments instead
of storing all of that data and
serializing it as json or some other
format bigquery actually keeps this idea
of a filled column and a depth column
which let you know if you're parsing
that data whether you're still in the
same field or not and honestly this goes
into more depth and I'm able to share
during this quick talk but to give you
an example here's what happens when you
select all of your fields big query will
actually generate a finite state machine
which figures out depending on what that
record field and depth field are how it
should traverse your document and then
from there it actually pulls apart that
finite state machine to parse it into
its own struck sore protobufs or
whatever it is this makes sure that if
you're parsing billions of records you
can do it extremely quickly without
having a lot of overhead of trying to
figure out sizing and allocations for
those results so we had a bunch of
tactics for making scanning on an
individual machine much quicker the last
one I'd like to share is this idea of
adding servers to increase efficiency
obviously if we're querying these
terabyte data sets on Google Cloud
Hardware it's much different than if
those data sets are just running on my
laptop within my own little database now
bigquery makes use of this same idea
effectively if you're a client you take
data or at first you hit the root server
and you submit your query and then
there's a set of intermediate servers
which are basically figuring out how to
fan out that query to individual leaf
nodes where each of those leaf nodes
then does only a small subset of the
work and passes back to the results
to get an example of what this looks
like let's say you're querying the root
node and maybe for this example you have
just one single layer in our tree if we
get our responses back that root node
officially has to merge all of our data
which could potentially be a lot instead
as is discussed in the paper and it's a
technique that's used behind the hood
what ends up happening is there are
different layers which each individually
split up the work so now if we issue a
query there are a bunch of intermediate
merges that happen so each node has to
deal with much much smaller data set the
great thing here is that more servers
effectively means more distributed work
and the fact that it's running in this
giant multi-tenant system that's been in
place at Google for the past 10 years
means that we have a pretty good
confidence that those servers are doing
a lot of shared computation and getting
good utilization so those are big
queries for good ideas in
column-oriented compressing data so it's
write quickly from a single node using a
fast nested data encoding which also
supports arrays and nested objects and
distributing the work especially by
separating data and compute let's look
at how that data model now maps into
personas and how nuts to bolts we're
using bigquery remember as I said before
we want to allow users to create custom
audiences these are just groups of users
who meet certain criteria we effectively
want to take this criteria and turn it
into more or less a sequel query with
custom parameters but how we do this
could be difficult right it's like we
have this kind of custom UI and if we
add new features to it we don't want to
then have to be building a bunch of
stuff on the backend to translate it so
what we do is we convert it to an
intermediate format we convert it into
JSON as part of an abstract syntax tree
and then from there we actually convert
that ast into raw sequel it's all
machine generated but to our user it
gives them this nice interface that
meets them on their level
well for us it gives us the power and
flexibility of sequel on the backend in
terms of how we're actually storing this
data we keep a data set per customer to
provide isolation and better monitoring
across them and then we keep a table per
each collection and event remember a
collection is just a type of thing
whether it's a user account or product
additionally we keep tables for things
like traits identity and merging and in
particular I want to call your attention
to this set of external IDs this is the
nested repeated format that bigquery
allows and it's one that you won't find
in a lot of other data warehouses or big
data stores the fact that this allows us
to specify multiple external IDs whether
it's an email or whether it's a database
ID or whether it's a stripe ID means
that if we want to query for any one of
those we can and we can be sure that
it's quickly findable and indexed and
that we're not spending a bunch of time
parsing JSON or trying to dig into these
objects it's right there as a top-level
field
additionally we end up exploding all of
these properties that the user passes in
in our v1 we actually stored these
specifically as JSON and kind of in its
own field but we found is that we
actually got much better performance by
exploding them out doing the alterations
of the table when we're uploading that
data and making sure that we're able to
query it quickly and efficiently so
let's look at the query patterns how's
this being used in production remember
this is the job of the commute service
the compute service is sending data or
sending queries across a handful at a
time as trying to run those as an
aggregate as sort of a cron job maybe
every few minutes it's saying okay
what's new with this audience for
customer a what's to do with this
audience for customer B what's new with
this audience for customers see what
this looks like under the hood and I
grabbed a few queries from our
production account is that this is
creating these tens of queries per
second which honestly look like garbage
it's because it's all machine generated
at the end of the day we don't care
about what these query
look like we only care that our
customers are able to have flexibility
when it comes to querying those
different data sets in terms of actual
query times we see good performance as
well we're able to query gigabytes or
terabytes in a matter of seconds or
minutes additionally this gives our
users the ability to preview particular
users who might fall into this audience
because they're able to interactively
query so they can check and see hey did
the audience ID bill actually work out
properly and we also give them insights
about potentially overlapping audiences
that they might have areas where user
IDs might also fall into this audience
looking at our numbers in production by
today we're currently scanning about two
gigabytes every single second which
corresponds to about a hundred and
seventy terabytes a day and we're using
about 800 slots so that roughly wraps up
our bigquery section we run our batch
computations here for tens of concurrent
queries
we're partitioning it by customer so we
get good visibility and isolation across
them and we end up keeping these
repeated arrays of external IDs so if we
want to query by a particular ID we can
let's shift gears through the speed side
of the equation now remember we want to
be able to query for this profile API in
this case we can't get data that's
minutes or hours old right but we also
don't care about querying for data
across all of our users instead we want
to get data in real time for the
specific user when they're on the web
page and that takes this bottom path the
speed layer the use cases here are much
different instead of having to crunch
our gigabytes or terabytes worth of data
across all users now we're simply
looking at kilobytes to megabytes of
data we want to primarily index it based
upon user and then maybe to a second
extent time and we need a high read and
write rate we're potentially doing tens
of thousands of queries per second here
and again data should be reflected in
real time we want this to happen in
under three
hundred to 500 milliseconds now what's
interesting when I was reading the
BigTable paper that this is actually not
that new of an idea it turns out Google
Analytics keeps their raw click table in
the same sort of format and so in terms
of building out BigTable for ourselves
we figured hey this actually makes a lot
of sense we just have to figure out how
to make it work with segments and to
give you an idea let's now dig into the
BigTable architecture so BigTable the
paper was released in 2006 and it talks
about a distributed storage system for
structured data effectively you can
think about it it's kind of a big key
value store where all of the keys
themselves are sorted so if you want to
get little bits of data or maybe a range
of keys you're able to do it under the
hood it looks something like this we
typically have a client which is making
queries to individual BigTable notes
each of those BigTable nodes are keeping
an in-memory data structure that they
call a mem table which you think of as a
sorted list of keys and values that are
append-only that then it also backs on
Associated Google file system tablets
these are the storage layer where we're
sure that we're persisting the data to
make sure that in case there's some sort
of crash or an instant throws away but
that data is still replicated and is
still durable here's what happens when
we issue it right first that right gets
directed to the right BigTable node via
some sort of master lookup table kind of
like chubby or another lock service and
then it actually gets appended to the
in-memory data structure on the node
itself before being backed or appended
to the backing storage as well well this
means is that writes are really fast the
end up being these fast appends that
don't require a lot of locking and you
can write extremely quickly but then
they're mirrored by the underlying
storage infrastructure reads similarly
can also be fast let's say we want to
read a new key if it's in our in memory
data structure which we can filter for
based upon using a bloom filter we can
probably whistle you detect that it's
there and then run a lookup in memory to
get a result that's
quick if that's the case then we just
pass back the value from that node and
we get a very quick read especially if
the locality is good if we've risked
written the value recently then chances
are it's probably still in memory if not
we actually fetch that offset from the
backing storage hardware and then we can
get it back now in this case reads first
cache and then they get merged together
so our right path is super fast but our
read path is pretty quick too because
it's coming from memory most of the time
and then it's just merging whatever the
diffs are together you might be thinking
though what about if there's an
underlying failure what if one of these
nodes goes down well in that case we're
okay to let's say we say have the same
read path which is fetching data from
our backing storage and this node dies
well because we've separated computing
from the underlying storage we're able
now just to move those portions onto a
newb a table node and claim that it now
has ownership and now we're able to just
read that same data which goes to the
same underlying storage and get it back
and those are the things that make
BigTable work really well for our use
case it's multi-tenant it's row oriented
uses a log structure merge tree under
the hood to ensure that there's fast
reads and writes it has a mutable
in-memory caching and it does a lot of
different tricks to make sure that an
individual node level it's saving us
both on reads and writes now let's talk
about how it comes to our data model how
segment a it fits into here
remember I said before that this is used
to query data about individual users so
we actually keep separate data's
separate data tables for each data type
we have one for records letting us know
who the user is we have one for
properties giving us various traits
about them and we have one for events
actually storing raw event payloads if
we want to pass those back to the front
end the keys are typically ID and time
ordered so that we're able to get a
range let's say give me the events that
happened
five minutes and the values are snapping
encoded so that if we want to pull them
we can do so quickly and efficiently in
particular when we stitch these together
we keep different tables for different
read and write profiles so we'll
actually use different ones depending on
what sort of query patterns we have I'd
like to wrap up by sharing a little bit
about how this has gone for us in
production in production today with
cloud BigTable we're currently writing
55,000 rows per second and reading a
little north of 3 X n we're storing 10
terabytes of data in this system and
it's all being powered by 16 different
nodes you can see here that we're
describing all of it within terraform so
if we need to make a change we can do so
quickly and easily for bigquery
we're running hundreds of queries per
minute this is a lot less than the
BigTable throughput because it's not
designed to be real-time it's only for a
small subset of users creating aggregate
pieces of data on top of their
individual user profiles here we're
scanning gigabytes of data per minute
and we're storing 500 terabytes worth of
data overall but let's get back to that
hard choice if we're choosing between
different clouds
I think bigquery is just straight-up
hard to compare there aren't many other
clouds off there which offer the same
sort of multi-tenant heavily
battle-tested infrastructure that
bigquery does it's able to give you
large amounts of data querying in
incredibly quick query times and to my
knowledge there isn't anything out there
with maybe the possible exception of
snowflake that even comes close when it
comes to actually using this data but we
will look at BigTable there actually a
few more alternatives out there which
seem to exist you could use dynamo you
could host your own sort of foundation
DB setup kind of whatever it is there
are a few different places where
BigTable actually really shines for us
now when we first started we end up
using dynamo and we kept running into
problems that made it really really hard
to work with
particularly around scaling cost and
identifying hotkeys and for those of you
who are familiar remember each BigTable
note host some set subset of keys so if
we have one user who is recording a lot
of data all at once or one particular
key that is sending hundreds of
thousands or tens of thousands of writes
per second that individual key gets
really hot it ends up being accessed far
more than the rest and finding those
keys can be tricky because typically
what will happen is they'll bring down
the rest of your infrastructure and just
slow everything down and it's incredibly
hard to figure out what happened so when
we were using dynamo we ended up
actually emitting metrics around these
hot keys and then coming up with a
system to figure out where this was
happening but in BigTable they just gave
it to us there's an out-of-the-box tool
that tells you what you're read and
write pattern looks like it tells you
how the keys are being accessed and you
can just go in and click and figure out
which users are hurting you most and
this system is honestly invaluable for
debugging because it immediately
highlights where the problems are the
second one is mostly around cost at
segment we have a very write heavy
workload most of the time we just have
all these events that are coming in and
it's honestly a little bit rarer that we
have users who are querying that data
via our API as it turns out BigTable is
much better at splitting this data
between compute and storage and what's
more unlike some of the other solutions
out there where you may be charged
differently for writes and reads for
BigTable you're charged the exact same
you're just charged for a node and so if
we want to be writing more data than
we're reading the cost profile actually
benefits us significantly because we're
able to separate that compute and
storage and just be charged for the raw
throughput rather than anything special
about our custom workload profile so in
closing I wanted to leave you with a few
thoughts this is a segment personas
powered by BigTable and bigquery
BigTable helps us for small random reads
bigquery is what we use for the batch
operations we're able to process
billions of events and we use a large
multi-tenant architecture so that each
customer's data gets their own
individual tables and data sets but that
were able to run the same compute
infrastructure everywhere this
infrastructure gives us favorable reet
and ride costs and already we've been
able to generate millions of dollars in
revenue from this new product initially
we have the firm knowledge that as we
continue to scale and grow many of these
systems that we have underlying will
change but we know that under the hood
both bigquery and BigTable are able to
scale out two levels far beyond what we
see today so if you're considering
building your own infrastructure upon
them I'd highly recommend investing
Google for your different data stores
thank you
[Music]